comme tout bon chineurs les
collectionneurs se sont levés aux
aurores pour dénicher la perle rare
alors à mener pour tout vous dire un
vélo des années 80 motobécane ce que mon
fils en fait s'intéresse à cette marque
là donc j'ai lâché pour lui à la bourse
aux vélos de puiseaux les visiteurs se
bousculent aussi du côté du marché de
l'occasion la plupart des cycles mises
en vente sont parties en à peine deux
heures ouais on a fait une heure et
demie de route
va pour trouver un vélo d'occasion à 30
euros c'est pas c'est pas cher du tout
donc ça peut valoir le coup allez c'est
bon
malheureusement avec l'aco ville c'est
très grande les vélos neufs c'est très
compliqué en avoir donc du coup les
vélos d'occasion ils ont ils ont
augmenté au niveau tarif est là vu que
c'est une bourse moto une bosse vélo
pardon
c'est accessible pour tout le monde quoi
et on voit le vélo de sur place tout de
suite on peut l'essayer c'est plus
pratique qu'internet cette année et
c'est inhabituel il y à des exposants
qui manquent à l'appel ce sont les
vendeurs de cycles 9
et les magasins bello pas revoir des
vélos c'est ici ça huit mois en oeuvre
du coup la déballer leur sol leurs
stocks sont bas sont tous vendus ce que
nous la bourse aux vélos c'est pour
déstocker leur leurs stocks et du tout
comme ils ont plus de stocks bas ils
viennent puis vendre chez nous la
pénurie de matériel et mondial elle
affecte les stocks de pièces détachées
alors la bourse de puiseaux devient une
véritable aubaine pour ceux qui veulent
faire durer leur vélo ou un jeu de
pédales pour mon vtt qui a déjà 10 ans
et
qui nécessitait que renouvellement de
pièces et donc je passe déjà par les
pièces détachées d'occasion avant
d'aller chercher des pièces neuves ce
qui en plus est de plus en plus
difficiles à trouver ce qui n'est pas à
vendre à puiseaux c'est la convivialité
entre les amateurs de la petite reine
dont le cercle ne cesse de s'agrandir
depuis la pandémie